[¿Una relación de amor o una relación de
odio?]
Queridos amigos, en este vídeo nos vamos
a ocupar de una relación muy especial. Tan
especial que está cerca, muy cerca, de cumplir
su 70 aniversario.
[Sí, el amor llegó a VisualPolitik.]
No os penséis ni por un
segundo hablamos de dos enamorados cualquiera.
Para nada.
Nuestros protagonistas se aman y se odian,
se necesitan y se desprecian al mismo tiempo.
Me estoy refiriendo al vínculo que une a
La Argentina con el Fondo Monetario Internacional.
Amigos, los argentinos una y otra y otra vez
se prometen que no van a volver a echarse
en manos de FMI, pero luego apenas unos años
más tarde la relación vuelve a florecer.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde mediados
de la década de los 50, de media Argentina
ha tenido que negociar un rescate del FMI
cada cuatro años y medio.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué demonios la Argentina
vuelve y otra vez a depender del FMI? ¿De
quién es la culpa? ¿Podrá en algún momento
esta relación llegar a su final?
Vamos a verlo pero antes, antes tenemos que
descubrir dónde comenzó este romance.
(EL ORIGEN DE UN AMOR TÓXICO)
En el año 1946 surgió el Fondo Monetario
Internacional como un desprendimiento de los
Acuerdos de Bretton-Woods del 44.
En aquel momento la Segunda Guerra Mundial
acababa de terminar, Europa estaba hecha añicos
y los aliados occidentales se preparaban para
hacer frente a las consecuencias económicas
y a la reconstrucción.
En aquel momento la idea que existía era
que había que evitar lo sucedido tras la
Primera Guerra Mundial, es decir había acelerar
la recuperación y evitar que se produjeran
crisis que pudieran inclinar algunos países
hacia movimientos radicales o incluso hacia
la órbita soviética.
Con esta idea, además del Plan Marshall,
a partir de Bretton-Woods se crearon tres
instituciones que hoy todos conocemos con
las que conseguir este objetivo:
(En primer lugar el FMI o Fondo Monetario
Internacional actuaría como prestamista de
última instancia para países con fuertes
desequilibrios fiscales o crisis cambiarias.
Es decir el FMI aportaría los recursos necesarios
para que estos países pudieran desarrollar
reformas con las que corregir sus desequilibrios.
En segundo lugar se creó lo que hoy conocemos
como Banco Mundial que se encargaría de ofrecer
préstamos con bajos tipos de interés y periodos
de amortización, de repago, de devolución
de los préstamos muy largos para ayudar así
a los países a financiar su reconstrucción
y llevar a cabo grandes proyectos de inversión.
Y finalmente el GATT, el Acuerdo General sobre
Aranceles Aduaneros y Comercio, la antesala
de lo que hoy es la Organización Mundial
del Comercio, que nació precisamente con
el objetivo de promover el libre comercio
y favorecer así el crecimiento económico.)
Pues bien, el caso es que en aquel momento,
aunque sea algo que hoy puede resultarnos
realmente extraño, lo cierto es que Argentina
era uno de los países con mejores condiciones
económicas del planeta; motivo por el que
fue invitada a integrar el FMI desde su origen.
Pero, amigos, Juan Domingo Perón, que acaba
de ser elegido presidente de La Argentina
no estaba por la labor. Digamos que tenía
en mente un modelo muy diferente para la Argentina
que no tenía nada que ver con esta especie
de integración económica a gran escala.
[Por cierto, en la descripción os dejo un
link a un vídeo donde os contamos quién
fue Juan Domingo Perón y que cambios hizo
en la Argentina.]
Sin embargo pronto las cosas cambiaron. Cuando
en 1955 fue derrocado por un golpe de estado
militar, la situación económica del país
ya era muy diferente: sin reservas, con altas
tasas de inflación y elevados déficit públicos
el presidente de facto Pedro Eugenio Aramburu
decidió incorporarse al FMI y solicitar una
ayuda de casi 1.000 millones de dólares en
valor actual, en valor de hoy.
El romance había comenzado.
[Y, sí, en ese momento la Argentina ya se
parecía más a la Argentina que hoy todos
conocemos.]
Pero, un momento. Puede que alguno os estéis
preguntado, pero… ¿Qué pasa? ¿Qué el
FMI da dinero por dar? ¿Le pides un préstamo
en condiciones más favorables y listo? ¿Es
una ONG o algo así?
Pues… No, no exactamente.
(Veréis, El FMI otorga financiación en unas
condiciones muy favorables pero también impone
condiciones que entiende son necesarias para
corregir los problemas y recuperar el dinero
entregado.
Eso sí, ningún pais tiene la obligación
de pedir ni de aceptar su ayuda. De hecho
hay precedentes de países que se han negado
a trabajar con este organismo. Pero si aceptas
su dinero y sus condiciones, luego no vale
decir que donde dije digo digo Diego, ¿No
os parece?)
Pues… lo cierto es que en el caso de Argentina
los incumplimientos llegaron muy pronto.
Atentos.
(LA HISTORIA REPETIDA)
Amigos, cuando Arturo Frondizi asumió la
presidencia en 1958 el país volvió a pedir
ayuda al FMI.
La condición en esa ocasión de este organismo
fue que a cambio de recibir el dinero la Argentina
tendría que impulsar un importante recorte
del gasto público y eliminar controles de
precios así como las restricciones a las
importaciones.
Pero no… Una vez que recibieron el dinero…
Luego, bueno, pues, digamos que el plan de
ajuste nunca se cumplió.
De hecho, el siguiente gobierno, el de Arturo
Umberto Illia decidió distanciarse de las
recomendaciones del Fondo, pero, claro, las
cosas no mejoraron, todo lo contrario.
Y tras el golpe militar de 1966 liderado por Juan
Carlos Onganía el país volvió a echarse,
otra vez, en manos del FMI.
En este ocasión las condiciones del organismo
internacional fueron más duras pero aún
así el gobierno Argentino no corregía sus
desequilibrios de tal forma que entre 1966
y 1973 la deuda externa argentina creció,
en un 50%, hasta los 4.800 millones,
el equivalente hoy a casi 30 mil millones.
Cómo veis, lo sucesos no se diferencian mucho
a lo que hemos vivido en los últimos años.
Pero el romance no había hecho más que comenzar.
(3 años más tarde en 1975 se produjo el
golpe militar de Jorge Rafael Videla. En ese
momento la economía está otra vez hecha
pedazos: el país venía de una crisis económica
que para que os hagáis una idea se tradujo
en el llamado Rodrigazo, una brutal devaluación
de la moneda del 100% sobre el dólar que
no solo causó una enorme inflación sino
también un desabastecimiento de muchos tipos
de productos.)
Y en esas circunstancias ¿qué pensais que
hizo el gobierno militar?
Exactamente volver a echarse en manos del
FMI.
De hecho el gobierno de Videla mantuvo unas
relaciones muy estrechas con este organismo
y un gran torrente de dinero del Fondo fluyó
hacia la Argentina.
[Sí, ya os hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik
que durante esa época en Washington se venía
con buenos ojos a cualquier dictadura que
no comulgara con el bloque soviético. Por
muy criminal que esta fuese. Seguro que eso
influyó en la enorme cantidad de dinero que
el FMI dirigió a la Argentina.]
El caso es que el gobierno de Videla en cierto
modo, sí. cumplió las exigencias del FMI
respecto a la estabilización económica.
Lo que no hizo fue recortar el gasto público,
con lo que los desequilibrios fiscales y la
demanda de fondos fue continua.
[Por cierto, en un próximo vídeo aquí en
VisualPolitik hablaremos largo y tendido de
las políticas promulgadas por el FMI y del
propio fondo.]
Y, amigos, el FMI no es una ONG, ni mucho
menos, sino un prestamista, que presta en
condiciones favorables sí, pero es un prestamista
que tiene la intención de recuperar su dinero.
Durante la dictadura, en apenas 7 años, la
deuda externa de Argentina se multiplicó
por 6 hasta alcanzar la bestial cifra de 42.000
millones de dólares de la época.
Evidentemente el país estaba quebrado. Y
para colmo este periodo bajo gobierno militar
terminó con el desastre de las Malvinas.
[De mal en peor.]
Tras ese último coletazo se produjo la vuelta
a la democracia con la llegada al poder de
Raúl Alfonsín el 10 de diciembre de 1983.
La democracia llegó con muchas expectativas:
(“Con la democracia se come, se cura y se
educa”. Raúl Alfonsín)
Desgraciadamente esta profecía nunca se cumplio.
Pero no nos desviemos. A su llegada al poder
Alfonsín rechazó al Fondo, incluso anunció
una auditoría de la deuda contraida por el
gobierno militar.
Todo un gesto de soberanía.
¿Sabés qué ocurrió?
Dos años más tarde, en 1985, bajo una colosal
montaña de deuda y una inflación creciente,
el gobierno de Alfonsín volvió a pedir ayuda
al Fondo. Ya sabéis hoy te quiero, mañana
no te quiero, pasado te vuelvo a querer, etcétera,
etcétera.
[Qué tierna historia]
(El FMI puso condiciones, pero las promesas
se quedaron en eso, en promesas, así que
el mandato de Alfonsín acabó de forma desastrosa:
con una crisis salvaje y una hiperinflación
de aupa. Para que os hagáis una idea la inflación
de 1989 fue de más del 2000%.
Y luego llegó Menem, y con él un nuevo apoyo
del FMI: el Plan Brady, un plan que obligó
a la Argentina a reestructurar su deuda externa,
privatizar el sistema de seguridad social,
privatizar empresas públicas, eliminar impuestos
a las transacciones financieras y crear una
nueva moneda atada al dólar para evitar la
endémica inflación del país.)
Durante la etapa de Menem, especialmente durante
su primera legislatura se hicieron muchas
cosas… Y funcionaron.
Pero no hizo lo más difícil: ajustar el
gasto público. De hecho, todo lo contrario,
bajo el mandato de este presidente el gasto
público continuó creciendo y con él la
deuda externa del gobierno. Fijaos.
(De esta forma el mandato de Menem terminó
con otra crisis enorme que acabó en el famoso
default de diciembre del 2001. Meses después
de que el FMI otorgara al gobierno de Fernando
de la Rúa un mega rescate de 40.000 millones
de dólares conocido como el Blindaje….Blindaje
que duró apenas 10 meses, hasta el definitivo
default de 2001.
Y después de eso llegó una nueva crisis
que hizo disparar la pobreza en Argentina
por encima del 50% de la población.)
Cómo veis, todos los rescates del FMI han
terminado siempre en un sonoro fracaso….
Y es normal. El FMI puede dar oxígeno a un
país para que este equilibre sus cuentas…
Pero si no lo hace, el resultado va a ser
siempre el mismo.
Y en Argentina se han hecho muchas cosas excepto
abrir realmente la economía y recortar el
gasto público y el tamaño del estado que
es gigantesco. ¿Queréis un ejemplo?
Pues… Fijaos el gráfico que ya os hemos
enseñado en alguna que otra ocasión. Pero
es que asusta de verdad.
Y ojo, no penséis que para el FMI esto ha
sido un plato de buen gusto. Para nada. Argentina
ha sido la demostración de la incapacidad
de este organismo. Ha sido algo así como
una humillación constante. Porque los políticos
argentinos aceptaban el dinero pero luego
nunca corregían los problemas.
Y así pues… claro, no se puede. Es que
no se puede.
Pero, ya se lo que estáis pensando.
¿Qué pasó con el Kirchnerismo? Nunca recurrieron
al FMI, ¿Por qué Macri si lo ha hecho?
Atentos.
(LOS KIRCHNER)
Los Kirchner no pidieron ayuda al FMI, es
verdad. Pero, amigos, esta historia tiene
trampa.
(Tras el default del 2001, Argentina nunca
llegó a pagar la mayor parte de su deuda
nominal, eso supuso toda una restructuración
que alivió las cuentas públicas. A esto
le tenemos que sumar que durante la mayor
parte de años del Kirchnerismo el precio
de la soja y de los recursos naturales que
el país exporta estuvieron por las nubes.
Eso supuso una enorme entrada de dólares.
Así que el gobierno de los Kirchner tuvo
margen, tuvo aire para seguir expandiendo
el gasto público sin tener que recurrir al
FMI.)
El problema es que eso es pan para un día
y hambre para el resto del calendario.
Cuando el precio de la soja y de otras materias
primas se vino abajo los problemas del gobierno
volvieron a estar bajo la mesa y por supuesto
regresaron los controles de precios, los controles
cambiarios y las restricciones de todo tipo.
Eso fue, precisamente, lo que llevó a Mauricio
Macri a la Casa Rosada.
(Pero con Macri las cosas tampoco cambiaron
esencialmente. El gasto público continuó
por las nubes y el gradualismo fue tan gradual
que la mayor parte de las reformas nunca llegaron.
El oxígeno se terminó y con él la autonomía
de la economía argentina. Así que en mayo
de 2018 el gobierno pidió un nuevo rescate
al FMI. En este caso de más de 50.000,
50 mil millones de dólares.
Y vuelta a empezar. El FMI pone condiciones
y los políticos argentinos no quieren cumplirlas,
la crisis crece y entonces los políticos
utilizan al FMI como chivo expiatorio. Luego
rechazan al organismo internacional, entonces
llega la etapa del odio. Y finalmente de nuevo
se echan a sus brazos.)
Amigos, esta es la historia de nunca acabar.
Desde los años 50, de media Argentina ha
pedido un rescate al FMI cada cuatro años
y medio. Y nunca han funcionado.
¿No es hora ya de cambiar? ¿No es acaso
el momento de que los políticos argentinos
entiendan que el país necesita un cambio?
¿No es acaso el momento de que el FMI entienda
que realmente nunca ha ayudado a la Argentina
porque ha prologando un escenario que está
llevando al país de mal en peor?
¿Qué pensáis vosotros?
Abramos debate, Dejadme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios. Si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvides suscribiros y darle
a like.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.